what's going on guys so as you can tell
by the title of this video this is going
to be a very interesting battle now
the embargoes up we can talk about the
12th gen Intel i7 12700 chipset and
we're also going to compare it against
the MacBook Pro M1 Max 16 inch we are
going to put these head to head on an AK
rendering scrubbing playback test now
let's talk about the build we have in
the PC here because we are very excited
on this this is an Aftershock build by
the way again it's the 12th agenda Intel
i7 12700 chipset we've got the GeForce
RTX 3070 graphics card 32 gigabytes of
ddr5 RAM one a terabyte of storage then
on the MacBook Pro we've got the 10 core
CPU 32 core GPU 64 gigabytes of unified
memory and two terabytes of storage
inside the 16 inch MacBook Pro this is
pretty much specced out minus the
storage on this which you can pretty you
can go much higher than two terabytes
but we've got this for our review set so
we've got Premiere Pro loaded on both of
these computers here what we're going to
be doing is we have 8K video footage
from our Nikon z9 review if you haven't
checked that out click on this but wait
after this video to watch that because
this is going to be a lot more fun and
more interesting so we've got 8-bit
h.265 video we've got 10 bit h.265 video
which is end log we've also got that
graded as well so you're going to see
the graphics card kick in on the PC as
well as the MacBook Pro when it comes
into that graded uh footage coming into
play so this is going to be a very
interesting test then afterwards we're
going to do a rendering test on both of
these and then we'll do rendering of
course with Final Cut Pro on the M1 Max
just to see if there's a big difference
between that and Premiere Pro versus the
PC obviously you can put Final Cut here
on that but we'll let the Intel cool
down a little bit and let the Mac just
do a couple more things you know because
we can anyway with that let's get down
to scrubbing Zach you ready
okay here we go we're gonna go on to the
PC with scrubbing AK footage
it looks like some drop frames Happening
Here
okay not bad some drop frames obviously
not the smooth discovering but it's much
better than previous now we go
to the MacBook Pro three two one go
okay
as you can tell no drop frames now I'll
expand the timeline a little bit so then
you can see a little bit more in terms
of a clip instead of all these clips put
it together see a little bit more
elongated and see if you can see any
drop frames in that regard three two one
[Laughter]
not bad right little stutters here and
there not too bad now we're gonna do the
same thing ready go
um
I think there's a clear winner on that
one I'm going to give that to the
MacBook Pro there's no drop frames
nothing that was smooth as butter
that was beautiful okay so now we're
gonna do a playback test so what we'll
be doing is playing back our 10-bit
h.265 and log footage now halfway
through it is graded and that's where
the graphics card will kick in a little
bit so that's where you'll see a
difference on the PC to the Mac or will
we let's find out
okay three two now as I mentioned
earlier there will be progress available
on this camera soon after launch but
right now you have hlg and N log and
we're actually shooting n log right now
h265 10-bit internal at 8K 25p
this is pretty damn impressive
break mirrorless camera system this is
impressive so we're gonna grade it
you're going to see the before and after
what it looks like on grade but uh I
gotta tell you about this camera is very
impressive and there goes a pelican
right there what I needed to shoot the
entire time
I missed it but I'm showing you analog
at 8K so there you go
damn it
so as we saw right there on the playback
it was pretty choppy
um even when we got to the graded end
log it was choppy as well so what I call
this smooth not quite but you know this
is pretty good I mean we're getting full
10 bit h.265 footage out of this we've
not done any sort of proxy on this this
is full resolution so now we go to the
MacBook Pro and when Max chipset and see
how that panels it okay three two now as
I mentioned earlier there will be Pro
rise available on this camera soon after
launch but right now you have hlg and N
log and we're actually shooting end log
right now h265 10-bit internal at 8K 25p
this is pretty damn impressive
great mirrorless camera system
this is impressive so we're gonna grade
it you're going to see the before and
after what it looks like on grade but uh
I gotta tell you man this camera is very
impressive and there goes the Pelican
right there what I needed to shoot the
entire time
I missed it
but I'm showing you n log in 8k so there
you go
damn it
so I think we have a clear winner on
that one I think the MacBook Pro M1 Max
performed beautifully with that no
dropped frames nothing choppy
that was smooth
so we've done the scrubbing test
the MacBook Pro
best of the Intel we've done the
playback test
the MacBook Pro has best of the Intel
thus far now we're not paid responsive
for this at all actually we didn't even
do these tests prior to this so we
really don't know what the outcome is
I'm actually impressed that it did that
well versus the Intel 12 gen I was not
expecting that but now we're gonna go to
rendering we're going to see how these
two machines handle the 8K footage we're
going to render it out in full
resolution for you
so with that let's get down to the test
let's have some fun
all right guys you ready three two one
go
how much time you got yeah we're gonna
be up a while though that means I have
to say I'm very impressed with the
MacBook Pro right now we're eight
minutes and 21 seconds remaining
uh on the PC where nine minutes and 42
seconds 41 seconds remaining
yeah
hey Jackie
you know what's interesting though
there's not even a fan on the MacBook
Pro actually there's not even a fan on
the MacBook Pro right now so looking at
this rum is about six minutes 30 seconds
right now it's kind of slow down a
little bit yours is seven minutes and
two seconds so you guys caught up a
little bit
maybe this
okay so they're almost neck and neck
right now I'm at 38 percent you're at 37
actually it's quite impressive they're
really neck and neck with each other
right now but anyway while we're waiting
I thought it'd be a good time to talk to
you about our sponsor Logitech here at
geek culture gaming is a way of life and
we always enjoy dishing out headshots
with the Logitech G Pro X super light
Mouse now the lightweight wireless mouse
combines excellent performance with the
classy No Frills look designed with pros
and engineered to Win It offers crisp
and responsive clicks the Smooth
Operator even allows you to swap out the
magnetic dongle storage compartment for
greater gliding ease check out all of
its other features over at Logitech
g.com okay so the MacBook Pro has
completed its download at 9 minutes and
18 seconds uh thereabouts uh we got
we'll put the exact number right down
below the screen here and we've got 30
seconds remaining and we're at 10
minutes and four seconds right now and
it's still going so I mean obviously the
MacBook Pro has won this challenge but
by how much
this is going to be very very
interesting to see how this plays out by
over a minute
by over a minute the MacBook Pros okay
so the PC finished in 10 minutes and 41
seconds and the MacBook Pro M1 Max
finished in 9 minutes and 18 seconds
they're about so running it down but
that's the difference between these two
uh machines
but there's something I didn't tell you
it's not been plugged in the entire time
and in terms of heat
it's just slightly warm
that's impressive
this
is extremely impressive
I've never seen a laptop do something
like this before
at least
an Apple laptop for that matter so as we
saw from the h.264 obviously MacBook Pro
dead best the Intel chipset however now
we're going to do it in prores through
Premiere Pro so we'll see how well both
these machines handle that three two one
go
uh it seems the PC is a little bit
slower right now
of course
I think Apple's whole system is really
built around prores for optimizing
prores I mean Final Cut just chews
through prores it's nothing to the to it
you know but this is very impressive
look at the bars just moving along
[Music]
dude this is chugging through I mean
obviously it's a little way slower than
Final Cut Final Cut was done one minute
17 seconds all right welcome to a
special segment where we ask facts about
Bobby so uh what's your Zodiac sign
Scorpio how do you feel right now
tired what's your favorite movie
Godfather one and two how tall are you
1.83
oh you didn't meet us man okay
hey I've been in Singapore for 14 years
I've converted to meters name three
things that you love
my dog
my partner and my mom
name three things that upset you three
things that upset me
slow computers
[Laughter]
telemarketing calls coming in
and
that's pretty much it I don't have three
things just two who's your favorite
celebrity crush
it depends depends right now
I love Margot Robbie I love Margot
Robbie all right all right what is your
favorite perfume
I don't wear perfume I'm a guy
okay what's your favorite cologne I
actually don't have one
just wear deodorant most of the time
what's up sponsors anyone out there
the thing you wanted to do in your youth
that you still haven't done many many
things I would love to travel the world
more I would have loved to
we're almost at 93 there right
um come on I know I don't know I don't
mean there's so many things you kind of
like we look back I think I'm more
traveling I think traveling would have
been a big thing for me and that's it
all right and 96 percent
while 74 and 97 percent
okay
final
I know it's too far already and done
by 16 or 517.
I mean honestly this is just impressive
dude the MacBook Pro is done at five
minutes and 17 seconds and the PC is
still going you got a you've done you've
rendered 85 of it at five minutes and 59
seconds I mean honestly I think this
chipset is obviously really good but
this goes to show how good the
architecture is in the M1 Max chipsets I
think from Apple I mean this is warm but
it's not hot
this is not even close to the heat that
I would feel on the 16 inch MacBook Pro
from 2019. that fan by from all the
testing we've done it would have sounded
like an air conditioning unit it was so
loud okay
about a little over two minutes more
on the PC versus the MacBook Pro
now what we're going to do is we're
going to want prores off a Final Cut
on the MacBook Pro M1 Max and see how
fast that is
let's do it right now just to give you a
heads up on this the MacBook Pro has
been unplugged this entire time
now usually laptops perform better when
they're plugged in versus unplugged
Apple has touted that no it performs the
same so what we wanted to do is run all
these Benchmark tests without a power
source into it on top of that there are
apps that are running in the background
of this as well
so now we're going to test to see how
fast prores rendering is
on Final Cut 10.6
let's do this
go es well
it's almost like a percentage a second
[Music]
it's almost done
it's at 85 percent
okay wow okay okay
that is
that's insane
that's I mean
I personally never seen numbers like
that and I don't own a Mac Pro so you
know for those of you who do own those
you probably have seen this but I have
not
um I've been using an M1 iMac as you
guys saw in my first impressions video
as a comparison
I mean that that to me was fast
this is on another level
so anyway I don't know what else to say
I'm kind of shocked all right guys so
that's our uh fun little test here at
the geek culture Studios with these uh
12th generation Intel i7 12700 chipset
of course we had the uh GeForce RTX 3070
uh GPU then of course we've got 32
gigabytes of a ddr5 ram one terabyte of
storage in the Aftershock computer in
this 16 inch MacBook Pro it was a 10
core CPU 32 core GPU 64 gigabytes of
unified memory and two terabytes of
storage so two very powerful machines
for anybody out there how do they
perform
man this Mac is good anyway hope you
guys enjoyed that subscribe and like
this video helps us out a lot take care
stay safe and we will see you in the
next one take care